I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Good morning. Today is very important. We have to do a very important legal procedure. Oh, Lord. I was like, wait, what's happening? And then I realized you're talking about the episode. The deposition. I was like, Jenna, what do we have to do? Did I miss an email? What's happening? No, we have a very important deposition today.
我是詹娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了这档终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享独家的幕后故事，这些故事只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。大家早安。今天非常重要。我们必须进行一项非常重要的法律程序。哦，天哪。我当时想，等等，发生什么事了？然后我意识到你在说这一集。那次听证会。我当时想，詹娜，我们必须做什么？我错过了一封邮件吗？发生什么事了？不，我们今天有一个非常重要的听证会。
Angela, it's season four, episode 12, written by Lester Lewis, directed by Julian Farino. Hit me with a summary. Here it is. Michael and Jan go to corporate. And Michael is deposed as a witness in Jan's wrongful termination case against Dunder Mifflin. What was Jan thinking? Why would you ever put Michael on any kind of witness stand? I don't know. I'm so glad she did. Well, while they're gone, Jim and Daryl play ping-pong in the warehouse, which sparks a rivalry between Pam and Kelly. Fast fact number one this week, Angela is Lester Lewis, the writer of this episode. Before writing on The Office, Lester had worked on The Larry Sanders Show and Caroline in the City. He was one of the original members
安吉拉，这是第四季第12集，由莱斯特·刘易斯编剧，朱利安·法里诺执导。给我来个剧情梗概。好嘞。迈克尔和简去了总公司。迈克尔作为证人，在简对邓德米夫林的非正常解雇诉讼中作证。简当时是怎么想的？你怎么会把迈克尔推上任何形式的证人席？我不知道。我太庆幸她这么做了。好吧，他们不在的时候，吉姆和达里尔在仓库打乒乓球，这引发了帕姆和凯利之间的竞争。本周第一条冷知识，安吉拉，是关于本季编剧莱斯特·刘易斯的。在为《办公室》撰稿之前，莱斯特曾在《拉里·桑德斯秀》和《城市女孩》工作过。他是我们创作团队的元老之一，
of our writing team going back to season one. And this is a tough one for me. And for both of us, I know Lester passed away in 2013. And I don't even know where to start. I loved him. I loved this man. We bonded over our love of autobiographical comic books. We both loved those. And I just have such fond memories of being with him. And he was so funny and he was so just kind and warm. He was so kind and just a good, good person. And I miss him. Yeah. I mean, Lester was someone that made time for everyone. You know those people, they make time for everybody. And he was just a wonderful part of our show. I re-listened to the DVD commentary for this particular episode. Lester is in the commentary. And it
可以追溯到第一季。这对我和你来说都是沉重的话题。我知道，莱斯特于2013年去世了。我甚至不知道该从哪里说起。我很爱他。我深爱着这个男人。我们因为都喜欢自传体漫画而结缘。我们俩都超爱那些。关于和他在一块儿的时光，我有太多美好的回忆。他那么幽默，而且总是那么善良和温暖。他心地善良，真的是一个极其好的人。我很想念他。是的。我的意思是，莱斯特是一个会为每个人抽出时间的人。你知道那种人，他们会为所有人留出时间。他只是我们剧集中极其美好的一部分。我重新听了这一特定剧集的DVD评论音轨。莱斯特也在评论音轨里。听到他的声音感觉太美妙了，同时也让我感到难过。
was so wonderful to hear his voice and also made me sad. It was bittersweet. But if you listen to the DVD commentary for this episode, you will just hear what a thoughtful person he was. And I'll share a few of the things that he said on the commentary as we record today, Jenna. I love that. Well, lady, what is your Fast Fact number two? You know, Ping Pong features very heavily in this episode. So I felt we needed a little history of Ping Pong. Oh, my gosh. Did someone do a deep dive on Ping Pong? I did. I want you to know it has two other names. Oh, Table Tennis or Wiff Waff. Wiff Waff. That sounds made up. Do you want to play some Wiff Waff? I'll play you some Wiffle Wiff Waff. Oh, dear. I'll chunk
这是苦乐参半的。但如果你听了这一集的DVD评论音轨，你就会听出他是一个多么体贴的人。在我们今天录制时，詹娜，我会分享一些他在评论音轨里说过的话。我喜欢这样。好了，女士，你的第二条冷知识是什么？你知道，乒乓球在这集里占比很大。所以我觉得我们需要了解一点乒乓球的历史。哦，天哪。有人对乒乓球做了深度研究吗？我做了。我想让你知道它还有另外两个名字。哦，台球或者“Wiff Waff”（击球游戏）。Wiff Waff。这听起来像是现编的。你想玩两把Wiff Waff吗？我跟你玩几把Wiff Wiff。哦，天哪。我要把它扔
it at you. What else you got about Ping Pong? Ping Pong began in Victorian England. I know you'll like the sound of that, Angela, in the 1880s, when lawn tennis players adapted their game to play indoors during the winter. Oh, where's my Netflix show about that? Right? Wiff Waff, Episode One. The Duke of Edinburgh comes to play Wiff Waff. The game quickly caught on in as early as 1901 tournaments were being conducted with over 300 participants. In 1902, a visiting Japanese university professor took the game back to Japan, where he introduced it to Japanese university students. The first world championships were held in London in 1927. They were won by a Hungarian, Dr. Jacobi. Congratulations. Dr. Jacobi. Go to see him
向你。关于乒乓球你还有什么知道的？乒乓球起源于维多利亚时期的英国。我知道你会喜欢这个的，安吉拉，在1880年代，当时草地网球运动员改编了他们的游戏，以便在冬天室内游玩。哦，我关于这个题材的Netflix网剧在哪里？对吧？Wiff Waff，第一集。爱丁堡公爵来玩Wiff Waff。这项运动迅速风靡，早在1901年就有超过300名参赛者的锦标赛了。1902年，一位来访的日本大学教授把这项运动带回了日本，并在那里将其介绍给日本大学生。第一届世界锦标赛于1927年在伦敦举行。冠军是一位匈牙利人，雅各比博士。恭喜。雅各比博士。去找他
for a checkup, but little do you know, he's a Ping Pong master. That's right. The Olympic Games started featuring Ping Pong for the first time in 1988 in Seoul. The television coverage of the men's singles final attracted a worldwide audience of two billion. Wow. Yeah. Here was something I found very interesting. There are many different ways to grip the paddle, and all of those grips have names. Oh gosh. Here's how you can hold it. You can give it the old penhold, the shake hand, or the sea miller. The sea miller is actually named after an American table tennis champ, Danny sea miller, because that's how he held his paddle. He puts his little finger out. That's what she said. There are also a bunch of different
做检查，但你根本不知道，他其实是个乒乓球高手。没错。奥运会在1988年汉城奥运会上首次将乒乓球列为正式比赛项目。男子单打决赛的电视转播吸引了全球20亿的观众。哇。是的。这里有一点我觉得非常有趣。握拍的方式有很多种，所有这些握拍方式都有名字。哦天哪。这是你可以采用的握拍方法：直拍、横拍或者“西米勒”握拍法。西米勒实际上是以美国乒乓球冠军丹尼·西米勒的名字命名的，因为他就是这样握拍的。他会把小拇指伸出来。这就是她说的。这里还有一堆不同的
strokes. Oh gosh. That's what she said. Oh Lord. There are offensive strokes, the hit, the loop, the counter hit, the flip, the smash. Then there's defensive strokes called the push, the chop, the block, and the lob. And the biggest part of the game, the biggest thing that these guys work on is their spin. And you can do a top spin, a back spin, a side spin, and a cork spin. Do you remember how good Forrest Gump was at Ping Pong? Yeah. He was so good. I wonder if he was using the sea miller. Maybe the penhold. I don't know. I think you do know that my husband turned our beautiful dining table into a ping pong table. Lady, I know this. I watched this happen, and I knew you were going to regret it. You
击球动作。哦天哪。这就是她说的。哦天哪。有进攻性击球，正手攻球、弧圈球、反击球、台内拧球、扣杀。还有防守性击球，称为推挡、削球、搓球和高远球。而这项运动中最核心的部分，这些家伙们最下功夫琢磨的，就是旋转。你可以打出上旋球、下旋球、侧旋球和回旋球。你还记得《阿甘正传》里的阿甘乒乓球打得有多好吗？对啊。他太厉害了。我在想他当时是不是用的西米勒握拍。也许是直拍。我不知道。我想你肯定知道我丈夫把我们漂亮的餐桌改造成了乒乓球桌。女士，我知道这个。我看着这事发生的，而且我知道你会后悔的。你们
guys were real excited, and I thought, hmm, that's going to come back. They haven't regretted it, Jenna. There's only one person that regrets it. Can we explain what Angela did, guys? Here's what her family did. They got one of these ping pong table tops that fits over her kitchen table. It's meant to go over a pool table, right? Oh. It's meant to set on top of a pool table. Josh got it because, you know, we've all been quarantining and at home, and so we're running out of things to do. Kids are bouncing off the walls. So we bought this thing because it's way less expensive than buying an actual ping pong table, and you just put it on top of your dining table. Of course, it doesn't fit our
当时可兴奋了，我想，哼，这事以后有得受了。他们没后悔，詹娜。只有一个后悔的人。大家能解释一下安吉拉做了什么吗？事情是这样的，她的家人买了一个可以装在她厨房餐桌上的乒乓球桌面。那是设计用来放在台球桌上的，对吧？哦。它是用来放在台球桌上面的。乔斯买它是为了——你知道的，我们都在隔离居家，所以我们开始找不到事情做了。孩子们精力过剩到处乱跳。所以我们买了这个东西，因为它比买一张真正的乒乓球桌便宜得多，你直接把它放在餐桌上就行了。当然，它不适合我们的
dining table, so it hangs off. Well, also now, guys, she has nowhere to eat. Okay, Angela, this is now your dining table. It's just, it's so, I don't know. Josh and the kids love it. What I didn't factor in, I knew I'd be eating, like, awkwardly for the rest of our time, but what I didn't factor in was the bouncing ball sound. I'm talking at, like, 8 a.m. because they want to play a game before school starts, you know? So it's like, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank. It is nonstop. Yeah. You come down the stairs, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank, bank. It doesn't matter what time.
餐桌，所以它会悬空出来。好吧，而且现在大家发现，她没地方吃饭了。好了，安吉拉，这现在就是你的餐桌了。这真的，我不知道。乔斯和孩子们很喜欢它。我没算计到的是——我知道在接下来的时间里我会吃得很别扭，但我没算计到的是弹球的声音。我是说，甚至在早上8点左右，因为他们想在学校上课前玩一局，你懂的？所以声音就是：砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。这声音没完没了。对。你从楼梯走下来，砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰、砰。几点都一样。
You've got that, and then all your appliances are beeping. Oh, don't get me started. It's so much noise. Anyway, here's an interesting tidbit from the commentary. Jenna, I know how much you love the wall in the writer's room with all the note cards, right? Yeah. All the different possible story ideas. That's one of my favorite things to go look at at my lunch. Well, Lester shared, there was one for this episode that didn't get used. Simply written, it was Dwight gets stuck in the wall. So if we didn't have this ping-pong competition, the other thing that might have happened is that Dwight was going to get stuck in a wall. Yeah. That was going to be Dwight's storyline. Instead of helping Jim or the ping-pong, I
你得忍受这个，然后你家里所有的电器都在哔哔叫。哦，别跟我提这个了。太吵了。不管怎样，这里有个评论音轨里的有趣小花絮。詹娜，我知道你有多喜欢编剧室里贴满便签纸的那面墙，对吧？对啊。所有各种可能的故事创意。那是我在吃午餐时最喜欢去看的景致之一。好吧，莱斯特透露说，这一集里有一个没被采用的想法。简单写着，就是“德怀特被卡在墙里”。所以如果我们没有这场乒乓球比赛，另一件可能会发生的事情就是德怀特会被卡在墙里。是的。那本会是德怀特的剧情线。而不是去帮吉姆或者打乒乓球，我
don't know how it would have played out. Ultimately, they couldn't make it work in this episode. So, oh man, I have to say, I love this ping-pong story. I also would have loved to have seen whatever about what's going to be. How would he have gotten in the wall? How would he have got stuck in there? I was laughing so hard when they were talking about it. That is some good stuff. All right. Fast fact number three is all about the writer's strike. Oh. Mm-hmm. This was the last episode of the office that we shot before the Writer's Guild of America went on strike and we had to shut down production. Now, this was really significant, guys, because NBC ordered 30 episodes for season four of The Office. 30. Wow. This was a huge episode
不知道这剧情会怎么发展。最终，他们没能在这一集里把这个点子做通。所以，天哪，我得说，我很喜欢这个乒乓球的故事。我也很想看看原本会是怎样的情节。他是怎么进到墙里的？他是怎么被卡在里面的？他们谈论这个的时候我笑得太厉害了。这真是不错的料。好了。第三条冷知识全是关于编剧罢工的。哦。嗯——哼。这是我们在美国编剧工会罢工并不得不关闭制作之前拍摄的《办公室》的最后一集。现在，这非常重要，伙计们，因为NBC为《办公室》第四季预订了30集。30集。哇。这是一个巨大的剧集
order. You know, typical seasons are like 22 to 24 episodes long, but then in November 2007, the Writer's Guild went on strike. So, if I remember correctly, Angela, we were allowed to shoot any outstanding scripts, but there could be no new writing done and we could not have a writer on set with us. Exactly. No writers were showing up to work, period. Well, we really relied on our writers to be on set with us while we were shooting. That was a big part of our process on the show is they would pitch alternates and they were so important to the show being great. And not only that, three of them were also actors. And Steve Carell was a member of the Writer's Guild Union and he would not cross
预订量。你知道，通常一季大概是22到24集，但在2007年11月，编剧工会开始罢工了。所以，如果我没记错的话，安吉拉，我们被允许拍摄任何现存的剧本，但不能进行任何新的写作，而且我们不能有编剧在片场陪同。没错。没有编剧来上班，句号。好吧，在我们拍摄时，我们确实很依赖编剧在片场。这是我们在剧集中制作流程的重要部分，他们会提出替代方案，对于这部剧的成功，他们至关重要。不仅如此，他们其中三人也是演员。而且史蒂夫·卡瑞尔是编剧工会的一员，他不会为了工作而跨过
the picket line for work. That's right. And I know that meant a lot to our writers that he stood with them. Yes. So, we shut down and any unused scripts were just tabled and the strike lasted over three months. Yes. And for those of you that are on the old Prager's belly tracker, the Kinsey Prager's belly, this was really weird because I left work not really showing and just wait for dinner party. Well, Angela, you also went out with some of the other actors and you picketed, I remember. I did. I went over and I picketed with our writers and I remember Ed was there the day that I went and it was very bonding experience. The Writer's Guild wasn't asking for the moon. They were just
纠察线。没错。我知道这对于我们的编剧来说意义重大，因为他与他们站在一起。是的。所以，我们停工了，任何未使用的剧本都被搁置了，罢工持续了三个多月。是的。对于你们这些关注老普拉格孕肚追踪器的听众，也就是金西普拉格孕肚，这真的很奇怪，因为我离开片场时肚子还不怎么显怀，然后就直接跳到了《晚宴派对》。好吧，安吉拉，我还记得你当时也和一些其他演员一起出去参加了纠察抗议。我去了。我过去和我们的编剧一起参加了纠察，我记得我去的那天埃德也在，那是一次非常增进感情的经历。编剧工会并没有要求过分的东西。他们只是
asking for really just basic, decent, fair treatment from studios. And I was really happy to help get their voices heard in any way that I could. Well, we always appreciated our writers, but I'll tell you, Angela, you and I are writing a book right now. And I will say there is nothing harder than staring at a blank piece of paper and putting something on it. Yeah, I know. I think that writers have the hardest job in our industry because all the rest of us, we get to start with something. We get to build on something that already exists, but the writers have to manifest it from nothing. Well, yeah, I know after the office, I went into development. As you know, Jenna, I wrote and I sold pilots and it was
要求工作室给予真正基本、体面、公平的对待。我真的很高兴能以我所能的任何方式帮助他们的声音被听到。好吧，我们一直都很感激我们的编剧，但我得告诉你，安吉拉，你和我现在正在写一本书。我必须说，没有什么比盯着一张空白纸并在上面写东西更难的了。是的，我知道。我认为编剧是我们这个行业里工作最难的，因为我们其余所有人，我们都可以从某些东西开始。我们可以在已经存在的基础上进行构建，但编剧必须凭空创造。好吧，是的，我知道在《办公室》之后，我进入了开发部门。如你所知，詹娜，我写过并卖出过试播集，那
so hard because not only do you write this thing that you love, it becomes your baby. Then you have to hand it over to like studio heads and network and they have all these notes and they just carve it up and you're like, my baby. Yeah, guys, we love our writers. Yep. And a lot of people always ask why was season four of the office so much shorter than the others? And that is why because of the writer strike. Yep. We made fewer episodes that year. Well, Jenna, we were very lucky because our show survived the writer strike. We both had many friends who are actors and writers and producers who were on shows and the strike went on for so long that they weren't able to resume. So we were actually really
真的太难了，因为你不仅要写出你爱的东西，它就像你的孩子一样。然后你不得不把它交给像制片厂负责人和电视台这样的人，他们有各种各样的意见，然后把它大卸八块，而你会想：我的宝贝啊。是的，伙计们，我们爱我们的编剧。没错。而且很多人总是问，为什么《办公室》第四季比其他几季短得多？这就是原因，因为编剧罢工。没错。那一年我们制作的剧集变少了。好吧，詹娜，我们非常幸运，因为我们的剧在编剧罢工中存活了下来。我们都有很多朋友是演员、编剧和制片人，他们在一些剧组工作，而罢工持续了太久，以至于他们无法恢复拍摄。所以我们实际上真的很
fortunate. Yeah. Well, there you go, guys. Lady, that's all I got. I have a fun little thing. It's not a fast fact. Maybe it's a Kinsey tidbit. What is it? Jenna, do you remember that Ed would do an impression of Tom Brokaw? Yes. And it would make us laugh. It was so good. It would make us laugh so hard. Okay. So what he would do is, Ed, as Tom Brokaw, he would start out telling a news story and then he would tell us what our hot snack of the day was on set. And there was a particular time where we had albandaga soup and he made that into part of Tom Brokaw's news announcement. And on the DVD commentary, they were talking about it, and Ed did it. Sam, will you play it? Could you give us the Tom Brokaw and say
幸运。好吧，事情就是这样，伙计们。女士，我所知道的就这些。我有一个有趣的小段子。这不是冷知识。也许算是一个金西小花絮。是什么？詹娜，你还记得埃德会模仿汤姆·布罗考（Tom Brokaw）吗？记得。而且总能把我们逗笑。太像了。能把我们笑得死去活来。好吧。所以他会做的是，埃德扮演汤姆·布罗考，他会先播报一则新闻，然后告诉我们片场当天的热门零食是什么。有一次我们吃了阿尔班达加汤（albandaga soup），他把它变成了汤姆·布罗考新闻播报的一部分。在DVD评论音轨里，他们谈到了这个，然后埃德现场表演了一段。山姆，你能放一下吗？你能模仿一下汤姆·布罗考并说出那个让史蒂夫发笑的魔性词吗？
the magic word that makes Steve Giggle? The Israelis have once again launched an all-pounder song on albandaga soup. That's what keeps us going. Oh my gosh, what a gem. I'm so happy that has been recorded. I know, I know. So if you guys want to know what behind-the-scenes moments were like, Ed was doing Tom Brokaw and John was doing impressions and we were all watching them and just cracking up. Oh my gosh, Angela, that actually brought tears of joy to my eyes. I know I'm very tired today and maybe that's made me a little emotional. But oh my goodness. Wow, that took me back. It did me too, Jenna. It just made me laugh and it warmed my heart. These were the behind-the-scenes moments that I treasure. Oh, all right. I'm
以色列人再次对阿尔班达加汤发起了一场全面进攻。这就是让我们坚持下去的动力。天哪，真是个宝藏。我太高兴这段被录下来了。我知道，我知道。所以如果你想知道幕后时刻是什么样的，就是埃德在模仿汤姆·布罗考，约翰在模仿其他人，而我们都在看着他们然后笑到崩溃。哦天哪，安吉拉，这真的让我感动得喜极而泣。我知道我今天很累，也许这让我有点情绪化。但天哪。哇，这把我带回了过去。我也是，詹娜。这只是让我大笑并温暖了我的心。这些就是我珍视的幕后时刻。好啦，好吧。我
going to let that take me into break. I'm going to pull myself together. We'll be right back. All right, guys, we are back and Michael is in a series of very important meetings. The first meeting is with the accounting department. Seems very serious. Pam comes in. Hands, Michael, post-it note. Yes, and Michael says with great authority after reading the note, you know what? I need to just call them back. I can't talk right now. Everyone is very perplexed when he does this, by the way. Well, Pam explains in her talking head that Michael does not get a lot of phone calls, but one time he got a phone call and she interrupted him during
要借此进入广告时间。我要调整好情绪。我们马上回来。好了，伙计们，我们回来了，迈克尔正在开一系列非常重要的会议。第一个会议是和会计部门。看起来非常严肃。帕姆进来了。递给迈克尔一张便利贴。是的，迈克尔在看完便利贴后以极具威严的语气说：你知道吗？我得回个电话。我现在不能说话。顺便说一句，当他这么做时，所有人都感到非常困惑。好吧，帕姆在她的单采镜头中解释说，迈克尔平时接不到多少电话，但有一次他接到了一个电话，当时她正在开会时用一张便利贴打断了他。他被这个举动逗得太高兴了，以至于现在他要求她每次开会时都这么做，但他其实根本没有电话打进来。所以她只能现编一个。
a meeting with a post-it note. And he was so delighted by this gesture that now he has asked her to do it every time he's in a meeting, but he doesn't get any calls. So she just makes it up. Yeah. Jenna, I would like to point out at 35 seconds, I'm titling this happiness in the break room. Oh, I think this is the most functional moment we ever see Jan and Michael. They're eating lunch together. She is laughing at whatever he's saying. Pam brings in the note. He says, you know what? I'll have to call them back. She's impressed. I think this is peak Jan Michael happy moment. Yeah, you're right. They're being so functional. I know. Well, we had a fan question about this series of notes from Mariana W. Walter
是的。詹娜，我想指出在35秒处，我把这称为“休息室里的幸福时光”。哦，我认为这是我们看到简和迈克尔最和谐的时刻。他们在一起吃午餐。她对他说的任何话都开怀大笑。帕姆送进便签。他说：你知道吗？我得回个电话。她印象深刻。我认为这是简和迈克尔的高光幸福时刻。是的，你说的对。他们表现得太和谐了。我知道。好吧，我们收到了粉丝关于这一系列便签的提问，来自玛丽安娜·W·、沃尔特·P·、菲利帕·J·和科琳娜·O·。帕姆递给迈克尔的便利贴是詹娜做的，还是为她特制的？伙计们，我没有做任何一张便利贴。没有一个字，没有一个涂鸦是我的。那个非常著名的、带有小热狗的“嗨呀，老兄”实际上是由我们的剧集主管格雷格·丹尼尔斯画的。
P., Philippa J., and Corinna O. Did Jenna make the sticky notes that Pam hands to Michael or were they made for her? Guys, I did not make any of the sticky notes. None of the words, none of the drawings are mine. And the very famous hiya buddy with the little hot dog that was actually drawn by our showrunner, Greg Daniels. Yes. Lester talked about it in the commentary and he said that Greg drew it just freehand quickly on their white message board, you know, in the writer's room. And then he had the props department come up and look at the drawing on the message board and they had to copy it and make it look just like the one on the message board. But then I heard they were not successful. And so they
是的。莱斯特在评论音轨中谈到了这一点，他说这是格雷格在编剧室的白色留言板上随手快速画的。然后他让道具部门过来看看留言板上的画，他们必须复制它，让它看起来和留言板上的完全一样。但后来我听说他们没能做好。所以他们干脆直接递给格雷格一张便利贴，让他自己重新画了一遍。不，这个我不知道。他们尽力了。不过我想指出一件事，当迈克尔和瑞恩之间的场景发生时，帕姆也在场，她递上了写着“嗨呀，老兄”的便签。然后瑞恩说：不，你应该接电话。接电话。是的。而迈克尔却说：不，你是我的朋友。我不会接的。他还在说：我跟你说，这是工作电话。接了吧。詹娜，你在这段情节中来回看着迈克尔和瑞恩的眼神，然后你拿起电话，按下分机号递给他的样子。太棒了。你
just handed Greg a sticky note and he redid it himself. No, that I don't know. They tried. I want to point out one thing though, as the scene is happening between Michael and Ryan and Pam is there, she's handed the note that says hiya buddy. And then Ryan's like, no, you should take the call. Take the call. Yes. And Michael's like, no, you are my friend. I will not. And he's saying, I'm telling you, it's a work call. Take it. Jenna, your looks back and forth to Michael and Ryan in this moment and then how you pick up the phone and you you hit the extension and hand it to him. It's so good. Your reactions made this scene for me. Oh, you're so nice. I love shooting that scene. It was so fun to watch them go
的反应成就了这个场景。哦，你太好了。我很喜欢拍那场戏。看他们俩你来我往真的太有趣了。我特别喜欢那些我只需站在旁边观看的戏。你知道吗？观众就是和这样的人产生共鸣的，因为观众会想：天哪，天哪，接下来会发生什么？到底怎么了？好吧，接下来，我们和简、迈克尔一起坐在车里。他们正要去某处。我们发现他们在去纽约市的路上，因为迈克尔要在简的不当解雇诉讼中作证。我们在1分53秒收到了来自维罗妮卡·赖特的粉丝抓包。你可以看到简在开车时穿着人字拖。哦天哪，真的吗？嗯——哼。那是因
back and forth. I loved the scenes where I got to just watch. You know what? That's who the audience is relating to because the audience is like, oh my god, oh my god, what's going to happen? What's happening? Well, next up, we are in the car with Jan and Michael. They're going somewhere. We find out they're on their way to New York City because Michael is going to be deposed in Jan's wrongful termination lawsuit. And we had a fan catch from Veronica Wright at one minute 53 seconds. You can see that Jan has on flip flops while she's driving the car. Oh my god, really? Mm hmm. Now that's because guys, Milora was really driving that car. You can see out the front window, we had a camera operator in
为，伙计们，梅洛拉（Melora）真的是在开车。你可以从前挡风玻璃看出去，我们有一个摄影师在后面，可能是兰德尔·艾因霍恩在拍摄这个。所以梅洛拉实际上是在开车并进行表演。再说一次，开的是PT漫步者，因为迈克尔的车还在修理厂，那辆赛百灵。就是他把它开进湖里的那辆。他还能拿回那辆车吗？我想我们以后会知道的。我不知道。这是我们第二次看到PT漫步者。简正在指导迈克尔该说些什么，而迈克尔决定记住他的证词的最佳方法是创造非常复杂的联想词。我都写下来了。太绝了。以下是迈克尔记住这场听证会内容的捷径。
the back, probably Randall Einhorn capturing this. And so Milora was actually driving and performing. And again, the PT Cruiser because Michael's car is still in the shop, the Seabring. From when he drove it in the lake. Does he ever get it back? I guess we'll find out. I don't know. This is our second episode where we see the PT Cruiser. Jan is coaching Michael on what to say. And Michael decides the best way to remember his testimony is to create very elaborate word associations. I wrote them all down. They're amazing. Here's Michael's shortcut to remembering things for this deposition. Jan says they displayed a pattern of disrespect and inappropriate behavior. Mm hmm. Michael says, Pat, turn.
简说他们表现出了不尊重和不当行为的模式。嗯——哼。迈克尔说：帕特，转弯。帕特，赚钱。我的朋友帕特转弯了。黛西雷。我的朋友黛西雷换了新眼镜。黛西雷，尊重。我的朋友内普罗开着普锐斯，后面跟着他的邻居。是的。然后简就问：这真的能帮到你吗？而他却说：哦，当然。我们发现简可能会赢得400万美元。那可是一大笔钱啊。确实如此。不过，迈克尔被简试图让他记住的信息压得喘不过气来。简有一句台词我觉得非常搞笑。她说：真相是非常复杂的。所以我们必须把细节过好几遍。詹娜，迈克尔需要把敞篷放下，因为他快要吐了。他快要呕吐了。他实在是太热、太慌乱了。
Pat, earn. My friend Pat took a turn. Desiree. My friend Desiree got new specs. Desiree respect. My friend in a pro drives a Prius with his behind neighbor. Yeah. And then Jan is like, does this really help you? And he's like, Oh yeah. We find out that Jan might win $4 million. That's a lot of guacamole. It sure is. Michael, though, is getting overwhelmed with the information that Jan is trying to get him to learn. Jan has a line that I thought was really funny. She's like, the truth is very complicated. So we had to go over it a few times. And Jenna, Michael needs the top down because he's going to puke. He's going to vomit. He's just getting too hot and flustered. Yes. Jan obliges even though
简只好顺从他，尽管这彻底弄乱了她的头发。现在我们在邓德米夫林总公司的前厅里。我们见到了简的律师，莱斯特·施耐德。他由帕特里克·奥康纳饰演，他还出演过《圣诞老豆》、《激情》和《实习医生格蕾》等影视作品。好吧，总公司这里有一些非常重要的植物警报。说来听听。3分33秒，一大盆竹子；3分49秒，一盆白兰花；3分53秒，正门外的一棵树状植物；3分55秒，一盆粉色兰花。搞什么鬼？他们有这么多植物。这是总公司。他们很高大上。确实如此。我们收到了来自加里·K·、索菲亚·A·、莉比·B·和马林·B·的粉丝提问。总公司
it completely messes up her hair. So now we're in the lobby of corporate Dunder Mifflin. And we meet Jan's lawyer, Lester Schneider. He was played by Patrick O'Connor, who has also been in Christmas with the cranks, passions and Grey's Anatomy, among other things. Well, I have some very important plant alerts at corporate. Lay them on me. Three minutes, 33 seconds, a big bamboo plant, three minutes, 49 seconds, a white orchid, three minutes, 53 seconds, a tree plant outside the front door, three minutes, 55 seconds, a pink orchid. What the heck? They have so many plants. It's corporate. They're fancy. They do. We had a fan question from Gary K, Sophia A, Libby B and Marin B. Where were the corporate headquarters
的场景是在哪里拍摄的？它们其实就在我们的仓库布景里。他们搭建了一个所谓的“摇摆布景”（swing set）。专业术语向你袭来。一点布景术语。所以“摇摆布景”是指他们搭建的一种可以随时组装和拆卸的布景。每当我们的角色去邓德米夫林总公司时，他们就会拉出这些墙，并且上面挂着所有的照片，以确保每次都做得一模一样。所以他们其实就是在邓德米夫林的仓库里搭了个摇摆布景进行拍摄。女士，我这里有一个关于总公司的微型取景地解析。是什么？带有所有兰花和植物的总公司前台接待区，也变成了听证会的房间。哦，是的。他们只做了
scenes filmed? They were just right on our warehouse stages. They built what is called a swing set. It's a little lingo coming at you. A little set lingo. So a swing set is something they build that they can put up and take down. And every time we had characters go to Dunder Mifflin Corporate, they would bring out these walls and they had all their pictures to make sure they did it exactly the same every time. So they were just shooting right over in the Dunder Mifflin warehouse on a swing set. Lady, I have a little location breakdown for you about corporate. What is it? The corporate reception area with all the orchids and the plants also became the deposition room. Oh, yeah. They only made
一套布景。他们先为总公司的所有前台接待场景进行了布景陈设。在总公司前台接待区的所有场景拍摄完毕后，他们进来重新布置，把整个房间改成了听证会房间。干得漂亮。嗯——哼。就是这样。太棒了。好吧，取景地解析来了。金西带来的取景地解析。哦，好吧，“金西百科”。金西，金西，“金西百科”。好吧，詹娜，在3分53秒时，瑞安在两个家伙的簇拥下走进来，对吧？ yep。莱斯特谈到了这个后来没有被采用的编剧们的连环恶搞桥段：瑞安只让自己被长相与他相似但个子比他矮的跟班们包围。我记得这个。现在，听着，
one set. They set dressed it first for all the front reception scenes at corporate. And after all those scenes were done in the front reception area of corporate, they came in, set dressing, redid the whole room and made it into the deposition room. Well done. Mm-hmm. There you go. So good. Well, location breakdown for ya. Location breakdown with Kinsey. Oh, well, Kinseypedia. Kinsey, Kinsey, Kinseypedia. Well, Jenna, at 3 minutes 53 seconds, Ryan comes in flanked by two guys, right? Yep. Lester talks about this runner that the writers came up with that ultimately didn't get to be in an episode where Ryan only surrounds himself by guys that look like him but are shorter than him. I remember this. Now, listen,
特洛伊，就是那个拿着黑莓手机的家伙。他会在其他几集里再次出现。嗯——哼。但这个被他身边一群长相相似但更矮小的人簇拥的整个构思最终没有被拍进去。不过特洛伊留下来了。回到邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司，吉姆和达里尔在仓库里打乒乓球。帕姆解释说，仓库里有了一张乒乓球桌，吉姆下来和达里尔打球，而她有时会带点果汁过去。情况就是这样。好吧，显然关于这些乒乓球比赛曾有过激烈的争论。他们应该用CGI特效制作球（你知道的，在比赛中）还是应该让你们真的打？没错。而他们决定让你们真的打。嗯——哼。他们在评论音轨中谈到，
Troy, he's the guy on the Blackberry. He's going to come back for a few other episodes. Mm-hmm. But this whole idea that he's surrounded by a posse of lookalikes but smaller but shorter that never made it in. But Troy stayed. Back at Dunder Mifflin Scranton, Jim and Daryl are playing ping-pong in the warehouse. Pam explains that the warehouse got a ping-pong table, Jim comes down to play Daryl, and she sometimes brings some juice. That's what's going on. Well, apparently there was a big debate about these ping-pong games. Should they CGI the ball, you know, in the game or should they let you guys really play? Yep. And they decided to let you guys really play. Mm-hmm. And they talked about it in the commentary
这简直是一场灾难，因为你无法保证连贯性。比如，他们无法确定演达里尔的克雷格每一次都会以同样的方式击球，或者约翰会以同样的方式回击。而你们在开始时建立乒乓球比赛的这段小戏拍了大约四个小时。简直是一场惨剧。太疯狂了。我还想说，安吉拉，球是有声音的。嗯——哼。而且它在我们的对话期间会在桌子上发出乒乒乓乓的声音。哦天哪，对声音部门来说一定太难了，因为你们在说话，然后就会有“砰砰砰砰”的声音。而且每次在不同的词语上面，它可能都会在不同的时间点发出砰砰声，对吧？哦，所以每当
that this was kind of a disaster because you can't have continuity. Like, they couldn't be sure that, you know, Craig as Daryl would hit it the same way every time or that John would hit it back the same way. And this little scene that you guys had at that beginning establishing ping-pong game took like four hours. It was such a debacle. It was so insane. I also want to say Angela the ball makes noise. Mm-hmm. And it would ping and pong on the table through our dialogue. Oh my gosh, that must have been so hard for the sound department because you guys are talking and then there's like bank bank bank bank. And then it's probably bank banking at different times on different words every time, right? Oh, so anytime the
镜头离我和敏迪更近一点时，就没有球了，对吧？嗯——哼。你可能会看到那些男演员做几个手势，但他们会试图获得干净的声音，因为乒乓球的声音——乒乓、乒乓、乒乓。是的。这会毁了一场戏。好吧，敏迪饰演的凯利有一句台词我非常喜欢，她说：“我不说垃圾话（trash talk），我说狠话（smack talk）。它们完全是两回事。”我想说我查过韦氏词典。你查了垃圾话和狠话。嗯——哼。哦天哪。上面是这么写的。垃圾话被定义为贬低、嘲弄或夸耀的评论，尤其是试图恐吓对方的对手之间。但你知道当你查到狠话时它怎么说吗？不。
camera comes a little tighter on me and Mindy, there was no ball, right? Mm-hmm. You might see some gestures from the guys, but they would try to get that clean sound because ping-pong, ping-pong, ping-pong. Yeah. Yeah. It's going to ruin a scene. Well, Mindy has a line as Kelly that I loved when she said, I don't talk trash. I talk smack. They're totally different. I want to say I looked this up in Miriam Webster Dictionary. You looked up trash talk and smack talk. Mm-hmm. Oh gosh. Here's what it says. Trash talk is defined as disparaging, taunting, or boastful comments, especially between opponents trying to intimidate each other. But do you know what it says when you get to smack talk? No.
它说：参见垃圾话。才没有呢。有的，确实如此。而我当时觉得这有点像是在说垃圾话的狠话。我必须这么说。词典简直是在对垃圾话进行疯狂内涵。是的。狠话就是在吐槽垃圾话。哦天哪。是的。我觉得这太搞笑了。我还想指出在这场戏以及整集中，吉姆的衬衫，他是把下摆放出来的，看起来很像他去年会时穿的那件。而且看起来大得夸张。是的。就好像——我知道这不是90年代，但完全可以是。好吧，詹娜，等会儿会有个镜头能让你非常清楚地看到帕姆的服装。我们待会儿会聊到。我有时间码。那是什么意思？你的语气里有很多情绪啊。
It says, see trash talk. No, it doesn't. Yes, it does. Which I kind of thought was a little bit of smack talk. I have to say. The dictionary is like throwing shade at trash talk. Yeah. Smack talk is trashing trash talk. Oh my gosh. Yes. I thought that was so funny. I also want to point out in this scene and throughout this episode, Jim's shirt, which he's untucked, it looks a lot like the one he wore to the convention. It also looks enormous. Yeah. It's like, I know this wasn't the 90s, but it could have been. Well, Jenna, there's going to be a moment where you get a real good shot of Pam's outfit. We'll get there. I have the time code. What's that supposed to mean? There's a lot of edge in your voice.
我知道我对这套衣服有很多想法。詹娜，你知道这个乒乓球的故事线是从我们编剧的真实生活里汲取灵感的吗？对啊，他们在仓库里弄了一张乒乓球桌，那些家伙以前经常在那儿打球。不仅仓库里有乒乓球桌，编剧们自己还做了一张乒乓球桌。李和简用一张普通的桌子做了这张乒乓球桌，有点像帕姆在会议室里做的那样。她做了这张桌子。好吧，编剧们在拥有真正的乒乓球桌之前就已经这么做了。所以这一切的灵感，就像那个使命召唤的故事线一样，都源于我们真正的编剧室里发生的事情。我完全记得那个。是的。就像
I know I had a lot of thoughts about this outfit. Jenna, did you know that this ping pong storyline was inspired by our writers real life? Yeah, they got a ping pong table town in the warehouse and those guys used to play all the time. Not only did they have a ping pong table in the warehouse, but the writers had made a ping pong table. Lee and Jean had made this ping pong table just using a regular table and kind of like what Pam does in the conference room. She makes this table. Well, the writers had done that before they got the actual ping pong table. So this is all inspired like that call of duty storyline by what was happening in our actual writers room. I totally remember that. Yes. And like
你说的，安吉拉，帕姆把会议室的桌子变成了乒乓球桌。她拉上百叶窗，告诉吉姆：你必须练习。你必须练习才能战胜达里尔。她还告诉了他关于凯利说狠话的事。而他说：好吧，我来。但我确实很喜欢吉姆立刻就说：哦，我打不过达里尔。不，那不可能。回到总公司，迈克尔遇到了黛安·凯利，公司法律顾问，由霍利·马普尔斯饰演。你可能会在剧集《谍影迷情》中认出她。她饰演埃莉诺·普林斯。而且他还发现托比将出席他的听证会。是的。而他说：我希望他离开。他在离开之前我什么都不会说。然后他们说：托比作为你的代表在这里，迈克尔。
you said, Angela, Pam turns the conference room table into a ping pong table. She closes the blinds and she tells Jim, you have to practice. You have to practice so that you can beat Daryl. And she tells him about Kelly's smack talk. And he's like, all right, I'll do it. But I did love how Jim immediately was like, Oh, I can't beat Daryl. No, that's not happening. Back at corporate, Michael meets Diane Kelly, the corporate legal counsel who was played by Holly Maples. You might recognize her from the show in plain sight. She played Eleanor Prince. And he also finds out that Toby is going to be present for his deposition. Yeah. And he says, I want him gone. I don't talk until he leaves. And they're
随后迈克尔宣誓。詹娜，我必须分享这个。我一定要分享。就在他宣誓的瞬间，有一个被删掉的镜头没有播出来。真的太棒了。迈克尔站起来对全场说：我有一份开场陈述。哦天哪，你是认真的吗？是的，太棒了。他对满屋子面无表情的人发表了一段非常走心的开场陈述。而他们的表情就像是：他在搞什么鬼？他表现得好像自己身处某种法律正剧电视剧中，就像他看过的所有关于律师的电影、所有的电视剧一样，他做了一场开场陈述。向陪审团的求情。这简直太荒谬了。太绝了。这在删减片段里。好吧，安吉拉，请告诉我你要播放这段剪辑。
like, Toby is here as your representative, Michael. Well, then Michael is sworn in. Jenna, I have to share this. I have to share. Right as he's sworn in, there was a deleted scene that didn't make it in. That is so good. Michael stands up to the room and says, I have an opening statement. Oh my God, are you serious? Yes, it's so good. He does this whole heartfelt opening statement to this room of just stoic faces. And they're like, what is he doing? And he does it as if he's in a legal drama, like television show, like all the movies he's ever watched about lawyers, every TV show, he makes an opening statement. A plea to the jury. Like it's so ridiculous. It's wonderful. It's in the deleted scenes. All
山姆，你能播放迈克尔的开场陈述吗？请继续。我想发表一份开场陈述。好吧。请简短一点。桌子前的各位女士先生，我只想说，我今天能来到这里是多么的高兴。但坦白讲，在我这个年纪，能去任何地方都是一种快乐。我只有44岁，所以我并不老。我想这个笑话并没有达到效果。但重点是，我很有幽默感，我恳请在座各位也同样具备幽默感。简，大卫，我绝佳的女友，我华丽的公司。为什么我们不一起深吸一口气，然后放松下来呢？很好。感觉不错。大家感觉好点了吗？我不知道该从哪里开始。
right, Angela, please tell me that you're going to play this clip. Sam, can you play Michael's opening statement? Continue. I would like to make an opening statement. Fine. Please be brief. Ladies and gentlemen of the table, I would just like to say what a joy it is for me to be here today. But frankly, at my age, it's a joy to be anywhere. I'm only 44, so I'm not old. And I guess that doesn't really play. But the point is, I have a sense of humor and I implore you all to have a sense of humor as well. Jan, David, my wonderful girlfriend, my gorgeous company. Why don't we all just take a big deep breath and just relax? Good. That feels good. Everybody feel better? I don't know where to begin.
他试图讲个笑话。没有达到效果。所有人都看着他，就像，就像他们内心已经死了一样。你知道我的意思吗？他们带着那种眼神。然后他说：好吧，那个不好笑。接着他恳请他们要幽默一点。这可是一场听证会啊。我们应该谈谈他的供词吗？有一件事我想指出，当简在6分35秒做单采时，你知道总公司的会议室有个名字吗？詹娜，你知道吗？什么？是的。总公司的会议室有一个牌匾。它有一个名字。你想听吗？什么？那是“罗伯特·米夫林纪念会议室”。那个牌匾是挂在简肩膀上方的墙上吗？是的。好眼力。谢谢。我太
He tries to do a joke. It doesn't land. Everyone is looking at him like, like they're dead inside. You know what I mean? They have that kind of gaze. And then he's like, okay, that didn't play. Then he implores them to have a sense of humor. It's a deposition. Should we talk about his testimony? One thing I would like to point out, as Jan does her talking head at six minutes, 35 seconds, you know, corporate has a name for their conference room. Jenna, did you know that? What? Yeah. Corporate's conference room has a plaque. It has a name. Do you want to hear it? What? It is the Robert Mifflin Memorial Conference Room. Is that hanging on a plaque over Jan's shoulder? Yes. Great catch. Thank you. I love
喜欢墙上的牌匾了，伙计们。随着迈克尔的证词开始，他很快就讲了一个“这就是她说的”的笑话。这彻底毁了听证会的进程，因为律师们对一切都信以为真。他们问：谁说的？她是谁？她说了什么？以下是律师提出的问题，而你当时一直直接在她下面。迈克尔，这就是她说的。太、太神奇了。他们对迈克尔的所有提问都太精彩了。在7分08秒，律师问：你认识原告多久了？迈克尔说：我实际上还没看过它（Plaintiff/Client发音相似），但我看过公司，而且我正打算去租《糖衣陷阱》（The Pelican Brief）。哦天哪。顺便说一句，
me the plaques on the walls, guys. As Michael's testimony begins, he very quickly gives a that's what she said joke. And it completely derails the deposition because the lawyers take everything literally. They're like, who said that? Who is she? Who is she? And what did she say? Here's the question the lawyer asked, and you were directly under her the entire time. Michael, that's what she said. It's so, so amazing. All of their line of questioning to Michael was so good. At seven minutes, eight seconds, the lawyer says, how long have you known the plaintiff? And Michael says, I haven't actually seen it, but I have seen the firm and I am planning on renting the Pelican brief. Oh my God. By the way,
我觉得约翰·格里森（John Grisham）没有一本叫《原告》的书。他应该写一本。那叫《糖衣惊魂》（The Client）。没错。并没有。我把他的书全看过了。我想让你知道，在这整集中，我非常欣赏那些前后呼应的彩蛋。是的，它们构思得太周全了。在这一幕中出现了一个重大的呼应，当时迈克尔展示了他为HR签署的文件，他的那份恋爱声明文件。这是对《鸡尾酒会》那一集的呼应，因为它被装在相框里。迈克尔说过他要把它装裱起来，他真的做了。它就在那儿，被装裱好了。而且他甚至懒得把它从框里取出来带到听证会上。他直接连框一起带来了。另外，安吉拉，在8分48秒时，迈克尔面前的桌子上有一个超级酷的邓德米夫林马克杯。
I don't think John Grisham has a book called The Plaintiff. He should. It's called The Client. That's right. It's not. I read them all. I want you to know. I really appreciated in this whole episode, I really appreciated the callbacks. Yes, they were so well thought out. A big one comes up in this scene when Michael displays his document that he signed for HR, his love document. It's a callback from cocktails because it's in a frame. Michael said he was going to frame it and he did. There it is framed. And he didn't bother to take it out of the frame to bring it to the deposition. He brought it in the frame. Also, Angela, at eight minutes, 48 seconds, there is a super cool Dunder Mifflin mug on the
你看到了吗？它是黑色的，带有银色字母。我看到了，我想，嗯，高大上的总公司果然有高大上的马克杯。我也想要这个杯子。我猜他们从来没出过这款杯子的周边。这真是一个错失的良机。这是一个很有品位的杯子。我很喜欢。是的，我们从来没得到过。没有，我们总是拿到带有蓝色字母的白色马克杯。请给我那个带银色字母的总公司马克杯吧。迈克尔有一句台词，詹娜，我不得不把它记下来。8分28秒。委婉地说，就是挂在我女人的胸前。哦，他对简的胸部的整段描述，你知道的，当他试图解释他为什么认为她被解雇是因为她做了隆胸手术时。但他就是不肯直接说出那句话。
table in front of Michael. Did you see it? It's black with silver letters. I did see it and I thought, well, Fancy Corporate has fancy mugs. I want this mug. I don't think they ever did merch of this mug. What a missed opportunity. It's a classy mug. I loved it. Yeah, we never got one. No, we always got the white mug with the blue letters. I want the corporate mug with the silver letters, please. Michael has one line, Jenna, that I had to write down. Eight minutes, 28 seconds. To be delicate, the hang off my lady's chest. Oh, his whole description of Jan's breasts, you know, when he's trying to explain that he thinks she got fired because she got breast implants. But he won't just say that sentence.
他说是因为那一对双胞胎。挂在我女人的胸前。说得委婉一点。它们会产奶。而他们的反应是：这家伙到底在胡说八道什么？好吧，这场听证会还要继续，但我确实觉得我们需要去斯克兰顿了解一下那里的情况。帕姆到处走动，一直在招募人员去会议室和吉姆练习打乒乓球。她对凯文说吉姆需要帮忙处理出差报销单，从而把凯文骗了进去。好吧，这把安吉拉和奥斯卡彻底搞糊涂了，因为你绝不会让凯文做这种事。在6分58秒，有一个镜头是安吉拉和奥斯卡看起来非常怀疑。为什么偏偏叫凯文去做任何事？这个镜头切得太高了，詹娜，
He says it's because of the twins. The hang off my lady's chest. To be delicate. They make milk. And they're like, what is this guy talking about? All right, this deposition is going to continue, but I do think we need to check in on the folks back in Scranton. Pam has gone around and has been recruiting people to practice ping pong in the conference room with Jim. She gets Kevin to go in there by saying Jim needs help, processing his travel receipts. Well, this completely confuses Angela and Oscar because you would never ask Kevin to do this. At six minutes, 58 seconds, there is a shot of Angela and Oscar looking very suspicious. Why is Kevin being called to do anything? The shot is cropped so high, Jenna,
他说这是因为双胞胎。它们挂在我女士的胸前。委婉点说。它们产奶。他们就像是，这家伙在说什么呢？好吧，这次盘问还要继续，但我确实觉得我们需要去斯克兰顿的老乡们那里看看。帕姆四处走动，一直在招募人们去会议室和吉姆练习乒乓球。她让凯文进去，说吉姆需要帮忙处理他的差旅收据。嗯，这让安吉拉和奥斯卡非常困惑，因为你绝不会让凯文做这种事。在第六分五十八秒，有一个镜头是安吉拉和奥斯卡看起来非常可疑。为什么凯文会被叫去做任何事？镜头切得太高了，珍娜，
that you don't see my belly. And also, Baby Jazz Poster is there. Still there? Still there. Hmm. You and Oscar have worked something out in regard to the Baby Jazz Poster. We'll never know. We never know. But it's made it back on the wall. I love the scene with Kelly and Pam in the doorway to the bathroom. Pam's leaving the bathroom. Kelly's entering the bathroom and they meet in the doorway. Who is going to let the other go by? Now, of course, custom would have it that you let a person exit, right? Same with elevators. Let the people get off before you push on. Yes, that's social etiquette. Yeah. But there's a standoff. So Pam moves aside and Kelly's like, yeah, that's what I thought. Kelly is so like aggressive
你看不到我的肚子。另外，小爵士海報也在那裡。還在那裡嗎？還在那裡。嗯。你和奧斯卡就小爵士海報達成了一致。我們永遠不會知道。我們永遠不會知道。但它又掛回牆上了。我很喜歡凱莉和潘在浴室門口的那個場景。潘正要離開浴室。凱莉正走進浴室，他們在門口相遇。誰會讓對方先過？現在，當然，按常理來說，你要讓裏面的人先出來，對吧？電梯也是如此。讓人們下車，然後你再擠進去。是的，這是社交禮儀。是的。但這是一場對峙。所以潘走到一旁，凱莉的表情就像是，沒錯，我就知道會這樣。凱莉真是
in this whole episode. She's just like hardcore. She's working some stuff out. Clearly. Before we go back to the deposition and discuss my favorite moment from this entire episode, I think we should take a break. What is your favorite moment? I don't know. Okay, wait, I'll wait till after the break. Okay, okay. Let me just say the star of this episode is the stenographer. Oh, yeah. Okay, I know the one. All right, we'll be back. We are back. And Angela, during the break, I asked Sam to please pull this clip of the stenographer reading back some of Michael's testimony. Oh, so this happened right after a commercial break of the show. The first scene back was just the stenographer reading.
在整集中都這麼咄咄逼人。她簡直就是硬核。她顯然在處理一些事情。顯然。在我們回到陳述錄取並討論我對這一整集最喜歡的時刻之前，我覺得我們應該休息一下。你最喜歡的時刻是什麼？我不知道。好吧，等等，我等到休息過後再說。好吧，好吧。我只想說，這集的明星是速記員。哦，是的。好吧，我知道是哪個。好吧，我們會回來的。我們回來了。安吉拉，在休息期間，我請山姆找出這段速記員宣讀邁克爾證詞的剪輯。哦，這發生在節目的商業廣告之後。回來的第一個場景就是速記員在宣讀。
And it's so brilliant. Sam, will you play it? Mr Scott, do you realize you just contradicted yourself? I did. Yes, you did. Can I go to the bathroom? No, I really have to. I've been drinking lots of water. You went five minutes ago. That wasn't to go to the bathroom. That was to get out of a question. You still have to answer it. First, can I go to the bathroom? No. She is perfection. Lady, we got so much mail about her. Caitlyn F, Brittany T, Lindsay H, Sarah C. Who is the stenographer? She is fantastic. How in the world did she repeat those lines back to the room with a straight face? And her cadence is so perfect. Guys, her name is Valerie Ross. She most recently
這太精彩了。山姆，你能放一下嗎？斯科特先生，你意識到你剛剛前後矛盾了嗎？我有嗎？是的，你有的。我能去洗手間嗎？不，我真的必須去。我喝了很多水。你五分鐘前才去過。那不是去洗手間。那是為了逃避一個問題。你還是得回答。首先，我能去洗手間嗎？不。她太完美了。女士，我們收到了關於她的好多郵件。凱特琳·F、布蘭妮·T、林賽·H、莎拉·C。這個速記員到底是誰？她太棒了。她究竟是怎麼面不改色地把那些台詞重新念給全場聽的？她的語調簡直太完美了。大家，她的名字叫瓦萊麗·羅斯。她最近
played the role of Eunice Simpson, OJ Simpson's mom in American Crime Story. But let me tell you, she has done a ton of work as a dramatic actor. But I went to her webpage and in her biography on her website, which is amazing, by the way, guys, I'm going to put a swipe up to it in the stories because her life is amazing. But I discovered that she completed the two-year program at Second City in Chicago, famous improv comedy. That's the same place that Steve studied. She also did improv with eight pieces of gold in San Francisco. She did comedy at the comedy store. She worked all over Los Angeles and improv theater. And yet her resume is like all dramatic work. It was so fascinating to me. I also have a
在《美國犯罪故事》中飾演了尤妮斯·辛普森——O·J·辛普森的媽媽。但我要告訴你們的是，她作為一名戲劇演員做了大量的工作。但我去了她的網頁，在她的個人網站的簡介上——順便說一句，這個簡介太棒了，夥計們，我會在限時動態里放一個上滑鏈接，因為她的人生太精彩了。但我發現她完成了芝加哥第二城喜劇團為期兩年的項目，那是著名的即興喜劇。史蒂夫也是在那裏學習的。她還在舊金山的「八塊金子」劇團做過即興表演。她在喜劇商店做過喜劇。她在洛杉磯的即興劇院各地工作過。然而她的簡歷看起來全都是戲劇作品。這讓我感到非常着迷。我和她也有過
connection with her. We both had guest starring roles on the TV drama Cold Case, not in the same episode, but I found that interesting, Valerie and I. I really felt like in my deep dive of Valerie Ross that it pointed to something that our show was so great at, which was hiring people for the realism, which made it funnier than if someone played it for comedy. That is right. That's why it's so funny is because when you hear her read off the testimony, it's like every courtroom you've ever gotten to look at, right? I don't know. I did jury duty. Have you done jury duty? I did jury selection. I was not ultimately picked, but you sat on a jury. I sat on a jury. What was your case? Can you say? First of all, I always
交集。我們都在電視劇《鐵證懸案》中有過客串演出，雖然不是同一集，但我發現我和瓦萊麗之間有這種聯繫很有趣。我真的覺得，在我深入了解瓦萊麗·羅斯的過程中，它指向了我們節目非常擅長的一個特點，那就是為追求真實感而招募演員，這比由某人來搞笑要滑稽得多。沒錯。這就是為什麼它這麼搞笑，因為當你聽她宣讀證詞時，就像你見過的任何法庭一樣，對吧？我不知道。我當過陪審員。你當過陪審員嗎？我參加過陪審團遴選。我最終沒有被選中，但你當過陪審員。我當過陪審員。你的案件是什麼？能說嗎？首先，我總是
get called for jury duty. And I don't know, Jenna. What is it? I always get picked. There's only been one time that I haven't been picked. I sat on a case and it was a car theft case. Okay. I was the alternate and you still have to go every day, but you actually cannot weigh in when you go to deliberate the case. You're only there if someone doesn't show up and then you can say something. So I just had to sit there quietly as they deliberate it. I couldn't say any of my opinions. It was very hard for me. Would they vote to convict or acquit? Equit. Would that have been your choice? Yes. Alright.
被傳喚去擔任陪審員。我不知道，珍娜。怎麼回事？我每次都被選中。只有一次我沒有被選中。我審理過一個案件，是一起汽車盜竊案。好的。我是候補陪審員，你還是每天都得去，但當陪審團去商議案件時，你實際上不能發表意見。你只有在有人缺席時才去，然後你才可以發言。所以我只能在他們商議時安安靜靜地坐着。我不能發表我的任何意見。這對我來說非常難。他們是投票判定有罪還是無罪？無罪。那是你的選擇嗎？是的。好吧。
So I maybe was making a lot of facial like responses as they talked. You know, I don't have a poker face, but while I was in this case, they did have the stenographer read back some testimony and this is exactly what it is. It's no nonsense. They just read it right back. There's no intonation. It's just exactly how Val did it. Do you know the famous story of Steve Carell showing up for jury duty? No. At the height of all of it, like 40 year old Virgin, Steve's blowing up his faces on billboards everywhere. He got called for jury duty. And you know, when you go to jury duty, they ask you questions. You get a sort of interview in the court. What is your profession?
所以我可能在他們談話時做出很多面部表情反應。你知道的，我沒有撲克臉，但在我審理這個案件期間，他們確實讓速記員重讀了一些證詞，這完全就是那個樣子。一點廢話都沒有。他們直接重讀出來。沒有任何語調。這完全就是瓦爾當時的做法。你知道史蒂夫·卡瑞爾出庭擔任陪審員的著名故事嗎？不知道。在一切的頂峰時期，比如《四十歲的老處男》播出的時候，史蒂夫紅透半邊天，他的臉到處都是巨幅廣告。他被傳喚去當陪審員。你知道的，當你去當陪審員時，他們會問你問題。你會在法庭上接受某種面試。你的職業是什麼？
Do you have anything about your life that might make you unable to deliberate this case fairly? All that kind of stuff. Right. Well, they asked Steve what his job was and he said, I am an actor. And the judge who did not recognize Steve said, do you do any other work as a day job? And he said, no, just the acting. And then he got placed on the jury. And he deliberated this, I believe it was some sort of civil case. Well, Jenna, the last time I went for jury duty, I think it's when Netflix had really kicked it into high gear for the office. And they went around and asked us each those questions. What is your occupation? And I said, I'm an actor. And he said, Have you ever acted on a law drama? The judge said this to me. I said, No, he said,
你的生活中是否有任何事情會使你無法公正地審理這個案件？所有這類事情。是的。嗯，他們問史蒂夫他的工作是什麼，他說，我是一名演員。不認識史蒂夫的法官問道，你還有做其他日常工作嗎？他說，沒有，只有演戲。然後他被安排進了陪審團。他審理了這個案子，我相信這是某種民事案件。嗯，珍娜，我上次去當陪審員時，我想那是Netflix真正把《辦公室》推向高潮的時候。他們走過來問我們每個人那些問題。你的職業是什麼？我說，我是一名演員。他說，你演過律政劇嗎？法官對我這麼說。我說，沒有。他說，
just, you just stick to workplace comedies. That's very funny. I said, Yes. And the whole courtroom started laughing. Clearly, the judge had watched the office. I know a lot of people always are trying to do these tricks to get out of jury duty, but I would love to be on a jury. I think the whole thing is fascinating. Sign me up. You know, it seems great. I think that's why I've been picked so many times before the office, because I actually show up with a notepad and a pin. I'm taking notes. And I think one side, either the prosecution or defense is like, we need her. She's taken notes. Yeah. Well, in summary, Valerie Ross is the star of this episode. She's incredible. She's so good. I wanted more stenographer. You know what I could listen to? I
你就堅持演職場喜劇吧。太搞笑了。我說，是的。整個法庭都笑起來了。很顯然，法官看過《辦公室》。我知道很多人總是想用這些把戲來逃避陪審團義務，但我很樂意加入陪審團。我覺得整件事都很迷人。算我一個。你知道，這似乎很棒。我想這就是為什麼我在《辦公室》播出前被選中那麼多次的原因，因為我確實帶着記事本和筆去報到。我在做筆記。我想其中一方，不管是檢方還是辯方都會覺得，我們需要她。她在做筆記。是的。嗯，總而言之，瓦萊麗·羅斯是這一集的明星。她太不可思議了。她太棒了。我想要更多速記員的戲份。你知道我可以聽什麼嗎？我
could listen to her read all of Michael Scott's testimony. That would be a wonderful extra feature. Imagine if Val had read back his opening statement. Oh my gosh. Oh, I want to contact her and see if she'll do it. That's amazing. Should we go back to Scranton, Angela? Jim has just beaten Meredith at Ping Pong in the conference room and Dwight Busson and he demands to know what is going on in here. Well, Jim says he's got a big client that plays Ping Pong and he needs to like impress him. So Dwight's like, I'll help you, right? Yes. And he's got this talking head where Dwight says all of his heroes are table tennis players. Who knew? And he lists all of these names of actual people. And in the commentary, Rain shared that they actually put those names on a cue card
可以聽她宣讀邁克爾·斯科特的所有證詞。那將是一個非常棒的額外特點。想像一下，如果瓦爾把他的開場白重讀一遍。哦，天哪。哦，我想聯繫她，看她願願不願意做。太棒了。我們該回到斯克蘭頓了吧，安吉拉？吉姆剛剛在會議室里的大胃王乒乓球賽中擊敗了梅麗蒂絲，德懷特闖了進來，他要求知道這裏發生了什麼事。嗯，吉姆說他有一個打乒乓球的大客戶，他需要給他留下深刻印象。所以德懷特就說，我來幫你，對吧？是的。他有一個訪談鏡頭，德懷特在裏面說他所有的英雄都是乒乓球運動員。誰會知道呢？他列出了所有這些真實人物的名字。在評論中，雷恩透露，他們實際上把這些名字寫在提示卡上
for him, a big cue card, so that he didn't have to memorize them. And he was able to read them off. Well, I'll tell you what, Angela, we had a fan catch. What? From Macy Gessler, who said, you can see a white square in the reflection of Rain's glasses during that talking head. That is the reflection of the cue card. That is such a great catch. And I paused and I looked at it and sure enough, it's there. Really? Oh, dang, I got to go back and look at that. That's so good. Big moment happening over at corporate. The deposition is going off the rails because this is when there's a lot of questioning about when did Jan and Michael's relationship really begin. And Michael has testified to one thing and they try to prove him wrong by showing this picture of Jan on the beach
給他看，一張大提示卡，這樣他就不需要背下來了。他就能直接念出來。嗯，我跟你說，安吉拉，我們抓到了一個粉絲彩妝失誤。什麼？來自梅西·格斯勒，他說，在那個訪談鏡頭中，你可以從雷恩眼鏡的反射中看到一個白色的方塊。那是提示卡的反射。這真是個大發現。我按下暫停鍵看了一下，果真在那裏。真的嗎？哦，該死，我得回去看看那個。太棒了。公司那邊發生了大事件。聽證會正在失控，因為此時有很多關於詹和邁克爾的關係到底是什麼時候開始的質疑。邁克爾作證說了一件事，而他們試圖通過展示這張詹在海灘上的照片來證明他說錯了
in Jamaica, call back to back from vacation that Michael accidentally sent to everyone as proof that their relationship started before the love document says it did. Jan's lawyer says that photo actually isn't proof. And we have Michael's journal to prove it. And Michael is like, what? Jan brought Michael's personal journal and they begin to read out of it. It's so embarrassing for Michael. Well, he's written all about his trip to Jamaica with Jan. And it's written like a 13 year old boy wrote it. It's written, Jenna, the way I would write in my journal, like when I was eight years old, Dear Diary. And then at the end, I'd be like XOXO. Like, what am I? Is the diary a person? Yeah, so it's like that or it's like me writing about
在牙買加，這是邁克爾不小心發給所有人的度假照片的回憶，以此證明他們的關係在愛情檔案所說的時間之前就已經開始了。詹的律師說那張照片其實不能證明什麼。我們有邁克爾的日記來證明。而邁克爾的反應是：什麼？詹帶了邁克爾的個人日記，他們開始朗讀其中的內容。這對邁克爾來說太尷尬了。嗯，他寫滿了他和詹去牙買加旅行的事。那口吻就像一個十三歲的小男孩寫的。珍娜，那寫法就像我小時候寫日記一樣，親愛的日記。然後在結尾，我會寫上XOXO。就像，我是什麼人？日記是一個人嗎？是的，所以就像那樣，或者就像我寫的關於
meeting Patrick Dempsey. Very similar. You know, Jenna and I journal, you guys, you know this, right? We shared the Patrick Dempsey journal on this podcast. Yes, we're big journalists. I counted actually how many journals I have. I don't even think I could count. I've got it over two dozen. I mean, so many. So many. I have 15. Oh, wow. Well, you know, lady, I did the artist's way. It's a 12 week self led creativity seminar in a book. It's amazing if you're an artist. But it requires you to journal three pages every single morning, first thing. So I have legal pads and legal pads of these handwritten journals from when I did the artist's way. And I did the artist's way twice because the first time I didn't finish it. So I have like so much journal.
見到帕特里克·德姆西。非常相似。你知道的，珍娜和我寫日記，夥計們，你們知道這個，對吧？我們在這個播客里分享了帕特里克·德姆西的日記。是的，我們是資深日記作家。我實際上數過我有多少日記本。我想我都數不清。我有二十多本。我的意思是，太多了。太多了。我有15本。哦，哇。嗯，你知道，女士，我做過藝術家的道路。那是書中一個為期12周的自我引導創意研討會。如果你是一名藝術家，這真是太棒了。但它要求你每天清晨雷打不動地寫三頁日記。所以我有很多很多從我做「藝術家的道路」時開始的手寫日記的法律記事本。而且我做了兩次「藝術家的道路」，因為第一次我沒有完成。所以我有很多日記。
Here is the journal entry that Jan's lawyer reads. I quote from an entry dated January 4 of this past year. Just got back from Jamaica. Tan almost everywhere. Jan almost everywhere. He, he. Oh, diary. What a week. I had sex with my boss. I don't know if it's going to go anywhere. Jan was very specific that it is not going anywhere, that it was a one time mistake. But we had sex with my boss. We had sex six times. So you tell me, I am definitely feeling very iry. But he says iry. And then Michael corrects him. Oh, more tomorrow. XOXO, Michael. Incredible. Angela, I looked up the definition of iry. You did? Yeah. The lawyer thinks he meant iry. But Michael's like it's iry. He's been in Jamaica. Yes. And it means nice, good or pleasing. And it is used as a general
以下是詹的律師宣讀的日記條目。我引用一下日期為去年1月4日的條目。剛從牙買加回來。到處都曬黑了。到處都是詹。他，他。哦，日記。多麼精彩的一周。我和我的老闆發生了性關係。我不知道這會不會有結果。詹說得很明確，這不會有任何結果，這只是一個一次性的錯誤。但我和我的老闆發生了性關係。我們做了六次。所以你告訴我，我絕對感覺非常iry。但他說的是iry。然後邁克爾糾正了他。哦，明天見。XOXO，邁克爾。太不可思議了。安吉拉，我查了iry的定義。你查了？對。律師以為他指的是airy。但邁克爾的意思是iry。他去過牙買加。是的。它的意思是好的、不錯的或令人愉快的，在牙買加英語中被用作表示贊同的通用
term of approval in Jamaican English. So despite everything, he's feeling pretty iry. I have to say Michael is absolutely crushed and feels betrayed by this reading of his journal. It is embarrassing. And he is right to feel that way. Jan is horrible. This was horrible. And this was premeditated. Yeah. She brought it from their home. Now they decide we're going to make copies of the journal. We're going to make 10 copies. Toby's like actually make it 11. Michael is just sinking further and further into this like embarrassing spiral. And Lester talked on the DVD commentary about one of the challenges of writing this episode was taking Michael through these layers, right? At the beginning of the deposition, he's feeling confident. And slowly with each
術語。所以儘管發生了這一切，他還是感覺相當iry。我必須說，邁克爾完全被擊垮了，並且覺得讀他的日記是對他的一種背叛。這太尷尬了。他這樣覺得是完全正確的。詹太可怕了。這太可怕了。而且這是蓄謀已久的。是的。她是從他們家帶來的。現在他們決定我們要複印這本日記。我們要複印10份。托比說其實複印11份吧。邁克爾正越陷越深，陷入這種尷尬的螺旋中。萊斯特在DVD評論中談到編寫這一集所面臨的挑戰之一，就是帶領邁克爾經歷這些層次，對吧？在聽證會開始時，他信心十足。隨着每一個
layer, it's just all falling apart. It's hard to believe that it's going to get worse from here. And yet it does. It's so tragic. And now they go to lunch. And everyone in this corporate lunch room is reading his journal. All I could think of was corporate has a cafeteria. I believed it, Jenna, because you know those big buildings in New York. I do. They have cafeterias and food areas. Ladies, I love a corporate cafeteria. I'll tell you what, I only experienced it once when I worked at the Coca Cola bottling company in Los Angeles. It's where they bottle the soda. I worked on the complaint hotline there. You did? I did. I took all of the complaints. And basically the policy was anyone who called a complaint got free coupons for soda. I had to listen to all the complaints
層次的推進，一切都在慢慢瓦解。很難相信從這裏開始情況還會變得更糟。然而確實如此。這太悲慘了。現在他們去吃午飯。這個公司餐廳里的每個人都在讀他的日記。我腦子裏想的全都是公司有員工餐廳。我相信了，珍娜，因為你知道紐約那些大樓。我知道。他們有餐廳和餐飲區。女士們，我喜歡公司餐廳。我跟你說，我只在洛杉磯的可口可樂裝瓶廠工作時體驗過一次。那是他們裝瓶汽水的地方。我在那裏的投訴熱線工作。你做過？我做過。我接聽所有的投訴。基本上公司的政策是任何打電話投訴的人都會得到免費的汽水優惠券。我不得不聽取所有的投訴
and log all the complaints and then mail the coupons. That was my job. It's kind of off in a remote area. This factory, you get 30 minutes for lunch. There's nowhere to go. So you had to bring your lunch or they had a corporate cafeteria. And lady, all the soda was free. You could drink as much as you wanted all day. The fountain sodas were free. But I love a cafeteria. I don't know what it is about it. I liked it when I was in high school. I loved it in college. I love a cafeteria. This is going to melt your brain for a moment. About a year and a half ago, I met my friend, Derek Haas, who works on Chicago Fire, Chicago PD. He's like the showrunner creator. He's like amazing, talented writer. We went to college together. He's like, and come have lunch.
併記錄所有的投訴，然後把優惠券寄出去。那就是我的工作。這有點在一個偏遠地區。這個工廠，你只有30分鐘吃午飯。無處可去。所以你必須自己帶午飯，或者他們有公司餐廳。女士，所有的汽水都是免費的。你一整天都可以隨心所欲地喝多少就喝多少。碳酸飲料是免費的。但我就是喜歡餐廳。我不知道是什麼原因。我上高中時喜歡它。我上大學時超愛它。我喜歡餐廳。這會讓你的大腦瞬間融化。大約一年半以前，我遇到了我的朋友德里克·哈斯，他在《芝加哥烈焰》和《芝加哥警署》工作。他就像是節目統籌兼創作者。他就像個了不起、才華橫溢的編劇。我們一起上過大學。他說，來吃午飯吧。
Let's catch up. I'm like, awesome. He's like, you know, our office is on Universal Studio lot. I said, yeah, he was like, so come meet me. We'll go to the NBC Universal Commissary. I said, what? He said, have you never been? You're on an NBC show. I was like, no, we filmed over in this little soundstage in the middle of nowhere. He said, oh yeah, NBC has an amazing commissary. What? Jenna, it looks like you're at the four seasons. I'm talking like fabric napkin, the water glasses that are the big glasses, you know, where your iced tea comes with like a lemon wedge. Yeah. Jenna, we never got the NBC Commissary treatment, but it was really good. I also went there years, years later to have lunch with Terry Weinberg, who is one of the executive
我們敘敘舊。我說，太棒了。他說，你知道我們的辦公室在環球影城外景地嗎。我說，知道。他說，那就來找我吧。我們去NBC環球員工食堂。我說，什麼？他說，你從沒去過嗎？你是在NBC節目里工作的人。我說，沒有，我們一直在荒郊野外那個小攝影棚拍攝。他說，哦，對了，NBC有一個超棒的員工食堂。什麼？珍娜，那看起來就像你在四季酒店一樣。我的意思是，有布製餐巾，那種大水杯，你知道的，裏面裝着帶有一片檸檬角的冰茶。是的。珍娜，我們從來沒有享受過NBC員工食堂的待遇，但那裏的飯菜真的很棒。我也在那裏很多年、很多年後去和特里·溫伯格吃過午飯，她是《辦公室》的執行製片人之一。
producers of the office. She works on the lot. She invited me for lunch at the commissary. And I thought the same thing. I thought, wow, Greg could have chosen to have our show on the lot, but he wanted us to be more independent and have our own space, which ultimately I loved and was the right decision. Except for that damn cafeteria. I mean, I would have really liked that. The cafeteria was legit. This is not to say that we didn't have the greatest food on our set because arcaders were amazing. I just really like a cafeteria experience. It's not the food necessarily. I love the tray and you go down the little thing with the silver bars. You know, I love a soup plantation. This is why I think Lady, you don't have to even talk about this with me. You've,
她在外景地工作。她邀請我去食堂吃午飯。我的想法也是一樣。我想，哇，格瑞格本來可以選擇把我們的節目放在外景地拍攝，但他希望我們更獨立，擁有自己的空間，最終我非常喜歡這個決定，這也是正確的決定。除了那個該死的食堂。我是說，我真的會很喜歡那個。那個食堂是貨真價實的。這並不是說我們片場沒有最棒的食物，因為大篷車非常棒。我只是真的很喜歡在食堂用餐的體驗。不一定非得是食物。我喜歡餐盤，你沿着帶有銀色欄桿的小傳送帶往前走。你知道的，我喜歡思派特餐廳（Soup Plantation）。這就是為什麼我認為女士，你甚至都不用跟我討論這個。你已經聽過
you've heard my thoughts on a Vegas buffet. I know. It's just things we like. Guess where we filmed these corporate cafeteria scenes. Angela, I know, but I'm not going to say you tell us at the Universal Studios Commissary. So crazy. We filmed them for one day. We rented the entire space. So everyone who is working there didn't get to eat lunch there that day because all the people in the background were hired by us for non-speaking roles. We had that cafeteria that day to shoot these lunch scenes. Well, Jenna, Michael is walking around the cafeteria and he doesn't know where to sit. Everyone's reading his journal. He's feeling a bit lost and you know he's at the bottom of the barrel when he goes and sits with Toby. And Toby tries. Toby is so kind. Yeah. He brings up his
我對拉斯維加斯自助餐的看法了。我知道。這只是我們喜歡的東西。猜猜我們是在哪裏拍攝這些公司餐廳場景的。安吉拉，我知道，但我不打算說，你來告訴我們——在NBC環球影城員工食堂。太瘋狂了。我們在那裏拍了一天。我們租下了整個空間。所以所有在那裏工作的人那天都不能在那裏吃午飯，因為所有背景演員都是我們為無台詞角色僱用的。我們那天佔有了那個食堂來拍攝這些午餐場景。嗯，珍娜，邁克爾在餐廳里四處走動，他不知道該坐在哪裏。每個人都在讀他的日記。他感到有些迷茫，你知道當他去和托比坐在一起時，他已經淪落到了谷底。而托比試圖幫忙。托比太善良了。是的。他提到了他
parents' divorce and how it made him feel. Both of his parents wanted him to testify and he's like, but I just love them both so much. Yeah. And he's sort of saying, Michael, I know you love Jan and you love Dunder Mifflin. So I see how you're pulled in two directions too. That's the subtext. Michael responds by pushing Toby's tray onto the floor and his entire lunch goes with it. So Lester talked about this moment. He said in the script they had written where Michael just goes off on Toby, like makes a big speech and they filmed it that way. And then Paul Lieberstein pitched, hey, why don't we do one take where he just shoves my tray off the table and walks away and doesn't even respond to me. And they did it. It was just like in the moment,
父母離婚的經歷以及這給他帶來的感受。他父母雙親都想讓他出庭作證，而他說，但我太愛他們倆了。是的。他有點像是在說，邁克爾我知道你愛詹，你也愛鄧德米弗林。所以我明白你為什麼也會受到兩股力量的拉扯。這就是潛台詞。邁克爾的反應是把托比的餐盤推到地上，他的整份午飯也隨之掉落。所以萊斯特談到了這一刻。他說劇本里寫的是邁克爾對托比大發雷霆，就像發表了一場大演說一樣，他們就是這樣拍的。然後保羅·利伯斯坦提出，嘿，我們為什麼不拍一個鏡頭，他直接把我的餐盤從桌子上推下去然後走開，甚至都不回答我呢。他們照做了。這就像是即興的想法，
idea in the moment. And that's what made it in. So good. So funny. When the deposition continues, they are still reading Michael's diary. They have some questions. They say, who is this other woman, Ryan, who you refer to? No, Toby cannot keep his composure. He is cracking up. Michael just so looks up to Ryan and his admiration of Ryan is one of my favorite little tidbits of the show. Well, he has a man crush on him. And you know, Ryan got to do all the things I think Michael had hoped for. He went to college. He got his MBA. He's at corporate now. He represents something to Michael that Michael always hoped to have. Yeah, that kind of status. And now they're going to start reading from Jan's performance review of Michael, which
當場想到的點子。最後這段被剪進去了。太棒了。太搞笑了。當聽證會繼續時，他們還在讀邁克爾的日記。他們有一些問題。他們說，這個你提到的另一個女人瑞安是誰？不，托比無法保持鎮靜。他快笑瘋了。邁克爾對瑞安真是仰慕至極，他對瑞安的崇拜是我在這部劇中最喜歡的小花絮之一。嗯，他對瑞安有着崇拜之情。你知道的，瑞安做到了所有我認為邁克爾所期望的事情。他上了大學。他拿到了MBA學位。他現在在總公司。他代表了一種邁克爾一直希望擁有的東西。是的，那種地位。現在他們要開始宣讀詹對邁克爾的績效評估了，
we find out she wrote after they were together. Oh, and her comments are so harsh and mean. Really mean. She recommends that he be let go from the company. She's out of carrots. She's out of sticks. Yeah, nothing works with Michael and that he's best suited for sales, which by the way, Jenna, I don't think she's wrong. I don't think she's wrong either. But this guts Michael. Yeah. He said, you expect to get screwed by your company, but you don't expect to get screwed by your girlfriend. We got some mail. We did. This is from Lou Chen, who says, as a lawyer who's taken depositions, I felt that the Michael deposition as depicted in this episode was impressively true to life while still being hilarious. And Kate P and Peter W pointed out something I
我們發現那是他們在一起之後她寫的。哦，她的評論是如此嚴厲和尖酸刻薄。真的很刻薄。她建議將他從公司解僱。她已經沒有胡蘿蔔可以用了。她也沒有大棒了。是的，對邁克爾來說什麼都不管用，他最適合做銷售。順便說一句，珍娜，我覺得她沒說錯。我也覺得她沒說錯。但這讓邁克爾心如刀割。是的。他說，你期望被你的公司坑，但你不會期望被你的女朋友坑。我們收到了一些郵件。我們確實收到了。這是劉辰（Lou Chen）發來的，他說，作為一個處理過聽證會的律師，我覺得本集中描繪的邁克爾聽證會令人印象深刻地逼真，同時又滑稽可笑。凱特·P和彼得·W指出了一點，我
thought was very interesting. Why didn't they use the documentary film footage for proof in the deposition? Oh, interesting. Yes. Interesting. They would have. They could have. Yeah. We could see a lot of stuff on tape. They didn't ask. But they agreed to have the cameras in the room. Yes. So interesting. Well, you know, Jenna, in the deleted scenes, there's a moment, you know, where Michael's like, listen, she didn't mean it. She was going through a divorce at the time. She was drinking a lot. And then Jan makes a face, right? And then Michael goes of water because she was taking all of those pills. He just keeps revealing all of the stuff that's making it worse and worse. And they had to trim some of that for time. But I just loved it.
覺得非常有趣。為什麼他們不在聽證會上使用紀錄片素材作為證據？哦，有趣。是的。有趣。他們本可以的。他們做得到的。是的。我們可以在磁帶上看到很多東西。他們沒問。但他們同意讓攝像機進入房間。是的。太有趣了。嗯，你知道，珍娜，在被刪除的場景中，有一個時刻，你知道，邁克爾說，聽着，她不是那個意思。她當時正在經歷離婚。她喝了很多酒。然後詹做了一個鬼臉，對吧？然後邁克爾說水，因為她當時在吃所有那些藥。他一直在泄露所有讓情況變得越來越糟糕的事情。為了控制時間，他們不得不剪掉其中的一些內容。但我真的很喜歡。
Lady, speaking of water, do you know how much water Tom Brady drinks every day? What? Yeah. Tom Brady? Where is this coming from? It's coming from the fact that the Super Bowl was recently. Yeah. And Tom Brady won. Yeah. And he looks like he's still 24. And I became a little obsessed with his athletic ability. And I read, and this is common knowledge, apparently, Lee was like, welcome to Tom Brady. Jenna, thanks for... I don't know it. What is it? He has this very, very, very strict diet that he adheres to. He has a personal chef. And he eats this mostly plant-based diet, but it also involves drinking gallons and gallons and gallons of water a day, like half his body weight in water. And all I could think about was, number one, this is such a
女士，說到水，你知道湯姆·布雷迪每天喝多少水嗎？什麼？是的。湯姆·布雷迪？這話從何說起？這源於最近舉辦了超級碗。是的。而湯姆·布雷迪贏了。是的。他看起來仍然只有24歲。我對他的運動能力有點着迷了。我讀到過，這顯然是常識，李當時說，歡迎來到湯姆·布雷迪的世界。珍娜，謝謝你……我不知道。是什麼？他有一個非常非常非常嚴格的飲食習慣，並且嚴格遵守。他有私人廚師。他主要吃這種植物性飲食，但也包括一天喝加侖又加侖又加侖的水，大約是他體重一半的水量。我腦子裏想的全都是，第一，這真是個喝水的
great advertisement for drinking water. But number two, how does he make it through a whole football game without having to pee constantly? How does he do it? I drink eight glasses of water a day, and I feel like all I do is pee. How does he drink so much water? And every time now, ever since learning this, that anyone brings up water, I think of Tom Brady. Well, maybe he does peter in a game. Maybe it just goes down his leg. I mean, you would never know. Oh my God, Angela. Listen, I would have thought that was crazy until, you know, Josh, who played soccer. Josh was a big soccer player all through high school, and he played in college. And he said, listen to this, he said on a soccer field during a long game, sometimes you can just like, take a knee
絕佳廣告。但第二，他在不頻繁上廁所的情況下是怎麼打完整場橄欖球比賽的？他是怎麼做到的？我一天喝八杯水，我覺得我除了上廁所什麼也沒幹。他怎麼能喝這麼多水？從那以後，每當有人提起水，我都會想到湯姆·布雷迪。嗯，也許他在比賽中真的尿了。也許它只是順着他的腿流下來了。我的意思是，你永遠不會知道。哦，天哪，安吉拉。聽着，我本來會覺得這太瘋狂了，直到，你知道的，踢足球的喬希。喬希整個高中時期都是個狂熱的足球運動員，他還在大學踢過球。他說，聽着這個，他說在漫長比賽中的足球場上，有時你可以像這樣，單膝跪地
and whip it out to the side and just pee for a second. So those soccer games, the guys are peeing. So when they're like, they're pretending to maybe lace their shoe or something. Yeah, yeah, they just flop it out and take a whiz. But football players wear super tight pants and stuff. I feel like you would see it. No, you wouldn't. It's all padded. You wouldn't see it. I bet they can pee in their pants. Oh my gosh, I need to know. Football players, someone right in. Have you ever peed during a game and did anyone know? Also, person who interviews Tom Brady next about his diet and about his water consumption, will you please ask him about this because I need to understand when and how often the man goes to the bathroom? I need to know. This seems unmanageable.
然後往旁邊一掏，順便尿個一秒鐘。所以那些足球賽，這群傢伙在隨地小便。所以當他們看起來像是在繫鞋帶或者幹什麼的時候。對，對，他們就是掏出來放個水。但橄欖球運動員穿着超級緊身的褲子之類的。我覺得你能看出來。不，你看不出來。全都是護具。你看不出來。我打賭他們可以在褲子裏尿尿。哦，天哪，我得知道。橄欖球運動員們，有人寫信來吧。你們有沒有在比賽中尿過尿，有人知道嗎？還有，下一個採訪湯姆·布雷迪關於他的飲食和飲水量的人，請你一定要問他這個問題，因為我需要了解這個男人什麼時候去洗手間以及頻率如何？我得知道。這似乎無法控制。
Here's my takeaway. Don't go on a road trip with Tom Brady unless you like making lots of stops. If we want to continue the Tom Brady tangent, I remember one time Lee and I read about the new house that he and Giselle purchased and it was humongous and it had like a gazillion rooms. And Lee said something that was so funny to me. He said, can you imagine if Tom Brady gets to the kitchen and he realizes he left his cell phone in the bedroom? How far he has to walk to get it? He's like, I get annoyed when I have to walk because I forgot something in another room. But think of how far they have to walk. And it's always stuck with me because it's true. You know what they do? They go like this and someone goes and gets it for them.
我的結論是：除非你喜歡頻繁停車，否則千萬不要和湯姆·布雷迪一起去公路旅行。如果我們想繼續深入探討湯姆·布雷迪的話題，我記得有一次我和李讀到他和吉賽爾買的新房子，那房子大得驚人，裏面有數不清的房間。李說了一句讓我覺得非常好笑的話。他說，你能想像如果湯姆·布雷迪走到廚房，卻發現他把手機忘在卧室里了嗎？他得走多遠才能把它拿回來？他說，當我因為把東西忘在另一個房間而不得不走路時，我會感到很惱火。但想想他們得走多遠。而這種情況總是留在我的腦海里，因為這是真的。你知道他們是怎麼做的嗎？他們會這樣一揮手，就會有人去幫他們拿。
Oh, they have a staff. They have a staff. That's what it is. The butler gets it. Tom Brady doesn't walk back to his bedroom for his cell phone. He's too busy drinking water. He's too busy peeing. Speaking of outstanding feats of athleticism, back in the conference room Dwight is beating Jim at Ping Pong. Dwight, it looks like he's barely making any effort to beat Jim. He's on his phone. He can just hit the ball no matter what. And Pam comes in at 16 minutes 21 seconds. Jenna, I'm going to show you your outfit. I took a screen grab of it. Oh, is it time?
哦，他們有工作人員。他們有工作人員。原來是這樣。管家去拿。湯姆·布雷迪可不會為了手機走回他的卧室。他忙着喝水呢。他忙着上廁所呢。說到非凡的運動壯舉，在會議室里，德懷特正在乒乓球桌上擊敗吉姆。德懷特，看起來他幾乎沒費什麼力氣就擊敗了吉姆。他還在看手機。無論如何他都能擊中球。潘在16分21秒時走了進來。珍娜，我要給你看一下你的服裝。我截了個圖。哦，是時候了嗎？
It's time because this is the moment. If you really want to see your outfit here, what is this outfit? What is your gripe about this outfit? We have black tights, a long black skirt just below your knee, a blue buttoned up sweater. I'm just saying, Pam went through this phase in the beginning of her courtship with Jim, where she was judging herself up a little. And I think this outfit says, I am now comfortable in my relationship. Do with that what you will. Well, I take it as an insult. It seems phrase that way. I think maybe Pam is just a little cold. It's winter. She has exchanged her pantyhose for tights,
是時候了，因為就是這個時刻。如果你真的想在這裏看看你的服裝，這究竟是什麼服裝？你對這套衣服有什麼不滿？我們穿着黑色連褲襪，一條剛過膝蓋的長黑色裙子，一件藍色鈕扣毛衣。我只是想說，潘在與吉姆戀愛的初期經歷過這樣一個階段，她稍微打扮了一下自己。我認為這套衣服說明，我現在對我的關係感到自適了。隨你怎麼理解吧。嗯，我覺得這是一種侮辱。聽起來像是這個意思。我想也許潘只是有點冷。正值冬天。她把絲襪換成了連褲襪，
which is something we did for her in the winter months. But I don't think she has gotten comfortable in any way. She just had a day where maybe she didn't pair the right things together. That is all. I think you'll see in dinner party coming up. She's going to wear an adorable little cocktail dress. So don't worry. All right, I will back off Pam's attire. It did crack me up. I have an observation about this scene. Jim keeps saying spin serve, spin serve. That is not a thing. I looked it up. Spin is not reserved for a serve. And of the top five table tennis serves, only three of the five involve any spin. And I'll tell you what they are. Number one, the short side spin pendulum serve. Number two, the short side spin reverse pendulum
這是我們在冬日裏為她做的事情。但我不認為她在任何方面感到自適了。她只是剛好有一天可能沒有把合適的衣服搭配在一起。僅此而已。我想你們會在接下來的晚宴派對中看到。她會穿上一件可愛的小雞尾酒裙。所以不用擔心。好吧，我不再挑剔潘的衣着了。這確實讓我笑出了聲。我對這個場景有一個觀察。吉姆一直喊着旋轉發球，旋轉發球。根本沒有這種說法。我查過了。旋轉並不是發球的專利。在排名前五的乒乓球發球中，只有三個涉及到旋轉。我來告訴你們是哪三個。第一，短側旋下蹲發球。第二，短側旋反手
serve. Number three is the fast no spin cross serve. Number four is the fast no spin down the line serve. And number five is the long side spin serve. So there's no such thing as just spin serve. You have to be more specific, Jim. Is it a short side spin? Is it a pendulum? Is it a long side spin? And by the way, just because you're putting spin on it, doesn't mean you're mastering the game because there's a couple of great serves that involve no spin at all. I don't know why I felt the need to put Jim in his place about this spin serve, but he was just saying it was such authority. And it's not a thing, Jim. It's not a thing. Well, don't tell my husband that because he thinks a spin serve is where it's at. He's going to spin it on over. Listen, it's just that
發球。第三個是快急不轉正手側身發球。第四個是快急不轉直線發球。第五個是長側旋發球。所以根本沒有什麼單純的旋轉發球這回事。你得更具體一點，吉姆。這是短側旋嗎？這是下蹲嗎？這是長側旋嗎？順便說一句，這並不是說你給球加了旋轉，就意味着你精通了這項運動，因為有幾個出色的發球根本不需要任何旋轉。我不知道為什麼我覺得有必要在這個旋轉發球問題上把吉姆雷厲風行地糾正一番，但他當時說得太理直氣壯了。根本沒有這回事，吉姆。沒這回事。嗯，別告訴我丈夫這個，因為他覺得旋轉發球才是王道。他會把球旋轉着打過來的。聽着，只是
it's just that there needs to be more specificity. Well, I'm going to tell him that next time he's playing while I'm trying to eat at the ping-pong table. Please do you put him in his place? Josh, that's not the long spin. Side spin. Short spin. That's a short spin. There you go. Well, Jim says he's ready. I'm going to go play Daryl. Pam's so excited they go down to the warehouse. And right away, it's not going Jim's way. And Kelly starts doing all of her smack talk, trash talk. She's making up a song. Hey, hey, you, you. I don't like your boyfriend. She's doing a whole thing. Pam has had it. Yeah. She's like, you and me right now, we're going to play. And they are both horrible. We had a fan question from Corinna Oh, Naomi Y and Lizzie M. Are you and Mindy actually bad
只是需要更具體一點。好吧，下次他在我試圖在乒乓球桌旁吃飯的時候打球時，我要告訴他。請你一定要糾正他。喬希，那不是長旋轉。側旋。短旋。那是短旋。這就對了。嗯，吉姆說他準備好了。我要去找達里爾玩。潘激動得跑到倉庫去了。馬上，事情就沒有按照吉姆的意願發展。凱莉開始大放厥詞，說垃圾話。她編了一首歌。嘿，嘿，你，你。我討厭你的男朋友。她整了一整套。潘受夠了。是的。她的態度是：你和我，現在就打一場。而且他們兩個都爛透了。我們收到了來自科里納、
at ping-pong or did you have to pretend? Let me say this. Mindy and I were not great at ping-pong, but we weren't that bad at ping-pong. So we were pretending to be that bad. And the point was that we would never get past a certain number of volleys. Are they called volleys in ping-pong? You should know. Oh, I didn't get that far in my research. And also, I know that John was actually good at ping-pong and he had to pretend to be not as good as he was. Yes. And by the way, we played a lot of ping-pong while we were just waiting for various camera setups and things like that. This was a really fun day of shooting, actually, because we had this toy, which then stayed in the warehouse and we would play. Well, and there are a lot of deleted scenes of all the
娜奧米·Y和莉茲·M的粉絲提問。你和明迪乒乓球技術真的很爛，還是你們不得不裝出來的？讓我這樣說吧，明迪和我的乒乓球技術並不算高超，但也沒有那麼爛。所以我們是故意裝作那麼爛的。重點是我們永遠不會超過一定的回合數。乒乓球里管這叫回合嗎？你應該知道的。哦，我的研究還沒做到那一步呢。而且，我知道約翰乒乓球其實打得很好，他不得不假裝自己沒那麼厲害。是的。順便說一句，我們在等待各種相機設置之類的空檔時，經常打乒乓球。這其實是拍攝中非常有趣的一天，因為我們有這個玩具，後來它留在了倉庫裏，我們經常玩。嗯，而且有許多其他辦公室成員在
other office members playing ping-pong that didn't make it in. Phyllis and Stanley play at the makeshift ping-pong table up in the conference room. Meredith has a turn. I yell off camera. I'm next. So it's like everyone is getting in there to play ping-pong. Lady, the deposition is almost over. And it's so sad because they've read David Wallace's testimony about whether or not he was ever really going to hire Michael for this corporate position. And you can tell in the testimony that David is really struggling to admit this, but the truth is Michael was never a real contender. Yeah, David says, listen, come on, he's a nice guy. Yeah. And he didn't want to have to go on record saying truthfully, Michael isn't anyone he considered. But you know what's interesting is of all of that crushing
會議室里打乒乓球的被刪除場景沒有被剪進正片里。菲利斯和斯坦利在鄧德米弗林會議室里那張臨時乒乓球桌上打球。梅麗蒂絲也輪到她了。我在畫外喊道。下一個是我。所以這就像每個人都加入進來打乒乓球一樣。女士，聽證會快結束了。這太令人遺憾了，因為他們宣讀了大衛·華萊士的證詞，關於他是否真的打算為這個公司職位僱用邁克爾。你從證詞中可以看出大衛真的很難承認這一點，但事實是邁克爾從來都不是真正的競爭者。是的，大衛說，聽着，拜託，他是個好人。是的。他不想公開承認說實話，邁克爾根本不是他考慮的人選。但你知道有趣的是，在所有這些令人心碎的
information. What Michael heard was that David Wallace called him a nice guy. Yeah. And when Jan's lawyer says, wouldn't you agree with Ms. Levinson that the company exhibits a pattern of disrespect towards its employees, Michael says, absolutely not. Yeah. He tanks her lawsuit. There goes the $4 million. Now they're only going to be able to get Chinese food for dinner. Oh, it's going to be a rough car ride home. But there is a very sweet scene where David Wallace goes up to Michael and is like, hey, I'm really sorry that you got drug into this. I never wanted that. And Michael's like, it's okay. There is this moment though, Jenna, where David is like the father Michael never had. And it looks like Michael is trying not to cry. Yeah. Like when
信息中。邁克爾聽到的是大衛·華萊士說他是一個好人。是的。當詹的律師說，難道你不認同萊文森女士的說法，即公司對其員工表現出了一種不尊重模式嗎？邁克爾說，絕對不是。是的。他把她的訴訟給搞砸了。400萬美元就這樣飛了。現在他們晚餐只能吃中餐了。哦，回家的車程將會很艱難。但有一個非常溫馨的場景，大衛·華萊士走到邁克爾面前說，嘿，我很抱歉你被捲入其中。我從來不想這樣。而邁克爾說，沒關係。不過有個時刻，珍娜，大衛就像是邁克爾從未有過的父親。看起來邁克爾在努力忍住不哭。是的。就像
your dad comes up to you and says, I'm sorry, buddy, you okay? It's like that moment. Yeah. And Michael's like, for the record, I think you're a nice guy too. It's a really sweet scene. It is. I have a great little behind the scenes trivia for you for that car ride home with Michael and Jan. Oh, tell me. Lester said that they had put lipstick cameras in the PT Cruiser for that car ride home. And when they got the footage back, it was all just completely dark. The little light that they had put in the car, like on the dashboard where you couldn't see it, it was going to illuminate Melora and Steve's faces. I guess there was something wrong with the light and it clicked off and all the footage was dark. Oh, no. So the only footage they had of that car ride scene
你爸爸走到你面前說，對不起，夥計，你還好嗎？就像那個時刻。是的。而邁克爾說，為了記錄在案，我也覺得你是個好人。這是一個非常溫馨的場景。確實如此。我有一個非常棒的關於邁克爾和詹回家的車程的幕後花絮要告訴你。哦，告訴我吧。萊斯特說，他們在PT巡洋艦上安裝了口紅攝像機來拍攝那段回家的車程。當他們拿回素材時，發現完全是一片漆黑。他們放在車裏的小燈，比如在儀錶板上你看不見的地方，本來是要照亮梅洛拉和史蒂夫的臉的。我猜燈出了點問題，它關掉了，所有的素材都是黑的。哦，不。所以他們擁有的那場汽車行駛場景的唯一素材
was from the follow car that was in front of them, right? Yes. So they had a car in front of them filming them. And that's the only camera that worked. And I actually really like it. And they talked about this a little bit in the commentary that it, it made it seem just way more real that there was this distance between the camera and what was happening. Kind of like what Randall talked about when he was on, the further away you were, the more intimate the moment feels to the viewer. Absolutely. This episode ends with an epic ping pong match between Dwight and Mose, who has left Shroot Farms, I believe for the first time we're seeing him off the farm. They are playing ping pong in the warehouse. It's clearly after hours it's dark, not all the lights
來自他們前面的跟隨車輛，對吧？是的。所以他們前面有一輛車在拍他們。那是唯一能用的攝像機。我其實非常喜歡它。他們在評論中稍微談到了這一點，這讓鏡頭和正在發生的事情之間的距離感顯得更加真實。有點像蘭德爾在他上節目時談到的那樣，你離得越遠，這一刻對觀眾來說就感覺越親密。絕對是這樣。這一集的結尾是德懷特和莫斯之間的一場史詩級的乒乓球比賽，莫斯已經離開了施魯特農場，這大概是我們第一次看到他離開農場。他們在倉庫裏打乒乓球。顯然已經過了下班時間，天很黑，並不是所有的燈
are on, and they are amazing. We had a fan question, Angela, from Ben S, Keith N, Bethany M, and Kai B were Rain and Mike Schur actually playing ping pong in this scene? Are they that good? No. No. This was all CGI. I think by this time they had learned how hard it was to actually film actors playing ping pong. So that was CGI. Yeah, those guys were just moving their arms and they put the ball in digitally in post. Before we wrap up this episode, you guys, there is a deleted scene that is delicious. It's Creed's turn to practice ping pong with Jim in the conference room at Dunder Mifflin. And Creed's like, yeah, I played, I learned to play in Cambodia. Jim's like, great, they start playing. Creed loses a point right out of the gate, starts taking off
都亮着，而且他們打得太棒了。安吉拉，我們收到了一位粉絲的提問，來自本·S、基思·N、貝瑟尼·M和凱·B：雷恩和麥克·舒爾在這一場景中真的在打乒乓球嗎？他們真的有那麼厲害嗎？沒有。沒有。這全都是CGI特效。我想當時他們已經意識到要讓演員真正打好乒乓球有多難了。所以那是CGI。是的，這幾個傢伙只是在揮舞手臂，而球是後期用數字技術加進去的。在我們結束這一集之前，夥計們，有一個被刪除的場景非常精彩。輪到克里德在鄧德米弗林會議室里和吉姆練習乒乓球了。克里德說，對，我打過，我是跟柬埔寨學的。吉姆說，太好了，他們開始打了。克里德一開局就丟了一分，開始脫掉
his shirt. Jim's like, hold up, what's happening? And Creed's like, but this isn't strip pong. And Jim's like, no, no, no. Creed's like, okay. Wow. Creed thought when you play ping pong, you have to strip when you lose a point. Oh, that's funny. I wish that stayed in. I know. That's what she said. Guys, that is the deposition. I hope you will join us next week for some Osobuko dinner party. Oh my God. Next week is dinner party. Yep. Holy crap sticks. Dinner party. We're here, Jenna. We'll show up for it, guys. I can't wait. I can't wait. All right, we'll see you then. Bye. Have a great week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive
他的衬衫。吉姆说，等一下，发生什么事了？克里德说，但这不是脱衣乒乓球吗。吉姆说，不，不，不。克里德说，好吧。哇。克里德以为打乒乓球时，丢一分就要脱一件衣服。哦，太搞笑这段要是保留下来就好了。我知道。那是她说的。伙计们，这就是《证词录》。希望大家下周能和我们一起享用ossobuco晚餐派对。天哪。下周就是晚餐派对。没错。天哪，太棒了。晚餐派对。我们到了，珍娜。我们会出席的，伙计们。我等不及了。我等不及了。好的，我们到时候见。再见。祝大家过个愉快的一周。感谢收听《Office Ladies》。《Office Ladies》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行
produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubakow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音师是萨姆·基弗，我们的助理制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码Office。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。